Hi everybody.
I'd like to welcome you
to our talk that's kind
of an interesting hybrid of
programming languages and
science, which usually,
I would say,
the two often don't go together,
but should more often.
So Andreas Stefik
is our speaker.
He is from University of Nevada,
Las Vegas.
And I first met him when he
was explaining statistics to
a speaker of the conference,
that was better than
the way that the speaker could
explain her own statistics.
And that was pretty nice
cuz Andreas is really,
he feels very strongly about
doing methodology properly.
He is a very proponent of
randomized control trials
especially when
you're dealing with
religious type of questions
such as these things that
will show up in programming
language design.
Lots of questions have been
around since the beginning of
programming languages that
are unsettled still to this day.
Andreas has been doing a lot of
research into trying to figure
out how to answer those
questions in a scientific,
data-driven way.
So let me hand it off to Andreas
to tell us all about that.
>> All right, thanks for
inviting me, Andy.
I appreciate it and I have the
distinct impression I'm going to
enjoy the dinner later as well.
There's a home cooked meal,
I've been promised.
I'm gonna help, though.
So as Andy said,
my name is Andy Stefik.
I'm a computer scientist by
trade, but I've spent quite
a lot of time with psychologists
and people sort of in that vein.
And I've spent the last
few years, especially,
sort of being especially
inspired by how other
fields solve really big
problems that the fields have.
So I kinda wanna start with
this story that was actually
a very famous test that
happened in the early 1800s.
And so
let me sort of set the stage.
There was this doctor,
it's 1834,
his name's Friedrich Wilhelm
von Hoven.
And at the time,
there were a variety of medical
doctors and practitioners that
were advancing this technique
that they called homeopathic
medicine, that was the name.
It started in the late 1700s by
this guy named Samuel Haldeman
and the idea was called
like cures like, right?
It was that if you have
a condition that's bad, and
you have a substance like that,
then may be that will cure you,
right?
Is that a good idea?
Well, it didn't hold
up to the evidence.
However, the problem is that
there was no way at that time
to really know for sure.
So von Hoven was really
skeptical that this might have
been fraud or at least he
wrote a letter about it.
His letters are very famous,
called The von Hoven Letter,
right?
It went to a local newspaper
from a newspaper owner that
was sort of anti-homeopathy,
if you will.
And it's very hard to read,
it's in, at the time, in 1834,
you can get the letter, but
the German letters aren't
the letters that they are today.
So even though my colleagues and
I have expertise in German,
it's very difficult to know
exactly what he's saying
without someone expertise and
early 1800s Germanic languages.
But words like charlatan and
fraud are used quite regularly
in this letter, right?
And what this led to was
actually a very famous test
called the Nuremberg Salt Test.
And it is widely regarded as
the first, what is called,
randomized control trial.
I'll get to this in a second.
But here's the problem,
the problem was at the time,
the doctors didn't really know
how to distinguish fact or
belief from belief or
from fiction.
They weren't sure how to
actually evaluate claims when
someone made them about
a medical practice or
other things.
So for example, von Hoven,
when he put out his letter,
he was challenged by
homeopathists of the day.
Homeopathists that were
getting money to practice,
especially from the aristocracy.
They were getting paid to do it,
so
they didn't want to
give up their practice,
of course, right?
And they didn't
trust each other.
So von Hoven and his colleagues,
which were also doctors,
they were saying things like,
well, we don't trust you, so
if we give a treatment
to patients,
we don't necessarily
trust them either.
So we don't want them to know
what they've been treated with.
And the homeopathists,
though, they're like, well,
we don't trust you either.
You're just gonna cheat and have
this fraudulent procedure, and
then your methodology
will show that we're bad,
even though we're not,
we're the good guys here.
And at the same time,
since neither one of
them trusted each other,
they crafted these procedures
to sort of prevent fraud.
And ironically, even though they
had fraud prevention procedures
in the test,
people still committed fraud.
And they were able to detect
it using some sly techniques.
It was the early 1800s, right?
So they weren't very good tests,
but
they were orders of magnitude
better than what existed before.
And because they didn't
know whether homeopathy had
an impact, they also had
a non-homeopathic treatment.
And there's all sorts of
test around the period,
some of them used things
like bread pills,
which is bread in a pill,
or they used water,
stuff like that.
I know, shocking.
But anyway,
as you can probably imagine,
the theory of like cures like
didn't really stand up to
the first experiment
a couple 100 years ago.
And why do they care about that?
There's really good reasons.
Medical doctors of
the age wanted more data.
He's hardly the only person of
the age that was very concerned,
there was doctors that were
concerned about washing your
hands cuz they were showing it
was killing pregnant women.
There was all sorts of horrible,
horrible things that actually
happen during the period,
in part, because there wasn't
a lot of science going on
in terms of our medical
practices of that age.
And of course, this led to
things like human death and
suffering and money going
to the wrong treatments and
fraud being sort of
propagated as a methodology,
even though it didn't work.
Or at least belief in something
incorrect, if not fraud.
So interestingly,
although this was 1834,
medical practices today still
have plenty of problems,
as I imagine many of
you probably know.
But there are procedures
now that are wildly,
wildly beyond anything we see
in a field like computer science
to detect fraud.
Especially today, corporate
fraud, cuz this has been a major
issue for a lot of reasons I
won't have time to go into.
But there is registration
of experiments.
There's replication
standards some fields have
that required by
law in some cases.
So it's very complicated and
tricky, but fascinating.
In any case, well,
I am starting with homeopathy.
The reason for that is that
even though this talks
about programming languages,
it turns out that there are some
parallels between
the evidentiary practices
of the early 1800s in medicine
to the evidentiary practices of
computer science today,
with notable exceptions.
And we know that this matters,
programming languages
are sort of foundational,
they're not the only
thing that matters.
There's all sorts of
conditions that are important,
like your processes, those
can matter, the technologies
you're using, the IDEs that
you're using can matter.
There's all sorts of factors and
it's a very complicated space,
just like it is in other fields.
It's not like
medicine is simple,
right, it's an extraordinarily
complicated search
base to try to navigate through.
And these languages that we
have, even though it's only one
part of the problem, it is an
important part of the problem,
for reasons I'm going to get to.
So for example, one thing that
you might think about right off
is, how much actually money do
we pay software developers?
So it's kind of a hard
question to get at,
there isn't data
from every country.
But if you just look at the US,
and you look at Bureau of
Labor Statistics data, and then
you look at software engineers
and people that sort
of support them.
So you can't really know how
many of the use languages and
how many don't, but you can kind
of get a sense of how much it is
and we peg that from VLS,
data about $330 billion.
All right, so it's not like
it's a small amount of money.
It's very expensive to pay
software engineers and
that makes sense.
Software engineers are highly
professional people.
They do hard jobs,
they work long hours.
It's a tricky thing,
it's important.
And what that means though
is that given the size of
the industry,
even a small difference in
programming languages, or
productivity by any metric,
can have a big impact at scale,
even if you only consider our
country, not necessarily others.
So, let's look at a case study
from Google on compiler errors,
just to get a sense.
So as you know,
Google tracks everything,
and one of those things in the
subset of everything happens to
be compiler errors
of their employees.
And if you look at that, they
published a paper a few years
ago on having tracked about
26.5 million compiler errors
from software engineers
using either C++ or Java.
Now, if you look at the data,
and we cut this up into
various ways and make a certain
assumptions that I can get into
later if you want, but it looks
at, Java developers had about
29.7% of the time,
they had compile errors, and for
C++ it was a little
higher 37.4%.
Again, these are experienced
software engineers
working in the industry
at a major tech company.
Yeah.
>> What type of errors
are [INAUDIBLE]?
>> These are errors where
the compiler rejected it, and so
they come in a variety
of categories, and
they tried to categorize them.
If you look on
the right on the graph,
these are the kinds of
categories that they gave.
But as you can probably imagine
sometimes it's a little
bit fuzzy,
if the compiler doesn't know
exactly what the problem was.
But other is a pretty
small category and
most of the time it was
things like dependencies and
type mismatch and
stuff like that. Yeah.
>> So, is it,
I see this on the bottom
you say percent of an eight
hour work day,-
>> Yeah.
>> But it looks like
the percentages sunk to 100.
>> Okay.
Okay, okay.
>> Developers certainly don't
spend all of their eight hour
work day fixing compiler issues,
right?
>> No, no,
no that's the point, in fact,
it comes out to be like 20-25
minutes or something of a day.
So, the point isn't so much that
that's not 100% of their day,
that's 100% of time, right?
I think is what their
graph means, so.
So if we made an assumption that
this was an eight hour work,
which is probably not fair,
right,
cuz people are gonna vary,
and stuff like that.
But if we made that assumption
for the sake of argument, and
we assume that Google's data
is accurate and honest and
all that kind of stuff as well,
then this comes out to be about
$5.9 billion for Java at scale,
and about 4.48 for C++.
Those are lots of
assumptions there.
We can't say that that happens
at scale, cuz we don't know.
But nonetheless, at least
at Google, it's enough of
money during the day that it's
a nontrivial amount of cash.
Yeah.
>> Actually it is just an
argument I would think, because
they haven't said anything,
or they didn't say anything,
about what actually is gonna
happen for that 25 minutes.
Maybe the programmers just
go home earlier everyday.
It doesn't necessarily
translate into actual money or
productivity.
>> I would agree with that,
yeah, we don't know that for
sure, you're right.
>> It says percentage
of build errors,
it doesn't say
anything about time.
>> I'm sorry, yes,
I apologise, yes this is, okay.
So they broke into
two categories,
one of the categories was time,
and I gave you those numbers for
just that piece, and then this
is the percentage of build
errors in terms of like how many
were they in this categories.
Thank you, you're right, that's
exactly what it's pointing out.
Okay, in addition, as it
turns out, besides industry,
education in the United States
at least in, not just in
the United States, but a bunch
of countries, are investing
quite a bit in computer
science for K through 12.
This isn't just industry,
this isn't just government,
it's a little bit of both.
So if you look at expenditures
from this report called
the BNY Mellon report it
doesn't look like that much.
It's like $12 or $13 million
across the states over the last
two years,
not exactly a lot of a cash.
Even the amount that Microsoft,
I don't remember the exact
numbers, has given to code.org,
significantly dwarfs this
overall, for all 50 states.
New York City gave $80 million
over a ten-year period, and
the Obama administration, before
it left, pegged it, if I recall,
around $4 billion is what is
necessary to really do it.
Now, does that mean it
will really happen?
I don't know, but
the point is that there's quite
a few government and industry
groups interested in having
computer science lower in part
because BLS data suggests
that industry needs more
software engineers.
It's a major problem that you
can look up very easily for
that type of stuff.
However, the thing that's funny
is that in order to teach
computer science at that
level you have to teach it in
something.
So it has to be in a programming
language unless you simply
choose to do all hand
gestures or something or
just conceptually
you could do that.
And it turns out there's
two major initiatives,
one of them is called,
exploring computer science.
This is an approach that was put
out originally by Jane Margolis
out of UCLA, and it's a very
specific curriculum that has
made specific choices about what
you do in the classroom, and
it happens to be polyglot.
So it uses seven programming
languages, so long as you define
programming language a little
more broadly than true and
complete.
So if you count
HTML as a language,
then that would be a language.
If you don't,
then it would be a handful.
The point is,
it's high school curriculum that
uses seven programming
languages for
whatever reason, and
I'm not defending or
refuting the position,
I'm saying that's a fact.
And one research team in
the United States picks it for
the whole United States,
that's how that works.
The second option that some
schools are doing that's sort of
up and coming options, is called
Computer Science Principles.
And so, in this particular case,
students basically take a test,
and if they do well,
they can get a little bit
of college credit for it.
No one knows what college
credit, but it exists.
This is programming
language neutral,
which has the opposite problem.
Since there's no one choice for
language, or even seven choices,
that means individual curriculum
designers make their own thing,
and as such a student in
Alabama might have a different
conception of what a loop is
than someone in Washington.
Now again, I'm not saying
that's good or bad,
I'm saying that that's true.
And these standards
are very different,
they're ratified by
the college board.
So they've been vetted by
a great number of computer
scientists over
a many year period.
And they're pretty sensible,
I mean like they say,
you should understand iteration,
you should understand
conditionals, whatever.
And if you look in college,
there's also no real consistent
sort of guidelines or standards.
So a few years back, we did an
analysis of just 39 colleges in
the Midwest and between them
they use C, C++, Alice, VB,
Python, Java, C#, COBOL, ADA.
And if you talk to
these individuals-
>> Isn't COBOL [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Actually there's-
>> Like what is
the name of the university
that uses COBOL [LAUGH]?
>> You'd be surprised, there's a
whole bunch of universities that
use COBOL, and it's for
a really good reason.
And one of them is because
during Y2K, they found that on
average, if you took a class on
COBOL, during that period, you
on average got $10,000 more on
hire than you would otherwise.
So as a university, it made
a lot of sense in that period to
do that, because of legacy code.
So I completely agree,
it's insane,
but on the other hand-
>> The year 2000 only comes
around once, right?
>> Well, we'll get to that, so-
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, [LAUGH] I know.
>> They still use COBOL.
>> Yeah, but in any case,
I'm absolutely not
defending the use of COBOL.
I'm just saying that,
when you go talk to people that
use particular languages,
they sort of fell into camps.
One group of people would say,
I use it because that's
what I'm told to use,.
And then other people would say,
I very strongly believe that
this is the right choice.
The individual,
whoever it may be that used ADA,
I think there's only one school,
really believed in that
particular approach.
Now, maybe he's right,
or she is right, but
the data doesn't
seem clear to me.
And as it happens,
these tools they are dispersed,
they have dispersion of designs,
right?
And it could be that
this doesn't matter or
could be that does it does.
So for example,
one language might say For
left paren equals 0, 1.
1 minus 10, 1 less than or
equal to 10, semicolon, i++,
paren left brace.
System.out.println, left paren,
double quote hello, minus,
double quote plus i, right
paren, semicolon, right brace,
rolls off the tongue.
Another might say stuff like,
repeat ten times,
output hello, stuff like that.
I'm leaving stuff out,
but you get the idea.
>> Even for
trivial traces, actually,
it does shows dispersion for
trivial traces.
But those languages actually
don't have a lot of dispersion
where concept, it wasn't like
you were saying, list and
then [INAUDIBLE] passed out.
>> Yeah, I think that's actually
true, so a lot of languages,
they don't show dispersion for
what their goals are, or
what they're trying to achieve.
They show dispersion in
the actual design to achieve it,
yeah, that's a good point,
that's totally true, yeah.
And here's a good example,
so generally speaking,
most languages have this concept
of string concatenation, right?
Being Microsoft,
I'm going to go on a limb and
say I don't have to
explain that concept.
And if you look at
the top example,
which happens to be Java,
then this concatenates.
If you look at
the example in the middle,
it happens to not, right?
Now, does it matter either way
what the choice is, maybe,
maybe not.
You could debate it, but
at the end of the day,
there is dispersion.
And in that context,
that means that
the design leads to
a different conclusion, right?
It doesn't do the same thing,
despite the fact that
we could agree or
disagree on whether the string
concatenation should be allowed
on a plus.
In other words,
as computer scientists,
we don't have much agreement
on even very trivial things.
And you might think that
this doesn't matter, but
in fact,
some types of technologies,
the dispersion gets
a little wackier.
So a good example is the web,
when the web was being
developed, it started with
things like HTTP protocol and
HTML, and
these sort of technologies.
And over time, we had different
needs, we needed to run it on
a server all of a sudden,
and have it take in logins.
And we wanted to manage
formatting in an easier way, so
we started making CSS.
And then someone was like,
I don't like CSS,
I need LESS, or SASS, or
these other technologies.
And they're different,
they're not compatible
necessarily, right?
TypeScript, Dart,
I mean, you name it,
right, on the server side,
it's the same situation.
There's a great deal
of technologies, and
they do very similar or
the same things.
But they do it in
a different way,
there's dispersion,
that's what I mean by that.
And the same with the database,
there's many variants of SQL,
NoSQL, stuff like that.
Again, this isn't good or
bad necessarily,
without evidence to support it.
It's just true, right, it's
that this dispersion exists,
right, and this has side
effects, potentially,
it may work in different ways.
So let's take this Y2K example,
which I happened to have
prepared ahead of time.
And as it turns out, during the
late 1990s, it's very difficult
to get good data on how
much it cost to fix Y2K,
and we've looked to the lot
of sources on this.
The best estimates we've seen so
far seem to peg it
between 300 and
800 billion for United States.
But we don't know for
sure how much it cost, and
if nothing else,
it seems like it's expensive.
Some countries track
it better than others,
some countries have their own
estimates, and they have some
evidence to support them, but
it's tricky to find out exactly.
But nonetheless,
it appears to have been
an expensive fix, right?
And Y2K only comes around once,
but the problem is,
as we progress as a discipline
over the next 40 or
50 years, it's not like
maintenance goes away.
So today, you might write
your web page with PHP and
HTML, and CSS, and SQL,
and whatever, right?
But in 40 years,
it could be that someone has
to maintain some of that code.
Some of it will die, and some of
it will need to be maintained.
So the question is, which
languages will live and die,
what is the evidence for
or against them?
And what's the cost of
maintaining a site built with N
programming languages?
>> [INAUDIBLE] Chaucer,
stuff like that,
you have the same
kinds of problems.
You have to learn a whole bunch
of new stuff to read Chaucer
[INAUDIBLE].
>> That's right, so the question
is, what does that cost, right,
that's the question,
longitudinally.
>> You'd end up with
[INAUDIBLE] stack,
and the fact that there's actual
benefits from things changing.
In terms of adaptivity of
language requirements, and
what people are trying to solve.
I'm just curious if you
factor the benefit and
not just the cost.
>> Yeah,
I don't think we disagree,
I think that this
is a cost-benefit,
that's exactly right.
But my point is that we don't
have a good estimate of what
those are, right, so I don't
think we disagree at all, so.
>> Do you think that this sort
of [INAUDIBLE] web maintenance
where things are change
in a very fluid and
constant fashion has
an impact on the issue of?
>> I don't know, it sounds
plausible, but I'm not sure,
I don't know of any
direct evidence for or
against the hypothesis, so.
There's one last issue I wanna
mention with this version that
I think people don't think
about that much, and
that is accessibility
technologies.
And when you look at
undergraduates in STEM,
about 11% of students have
documented disabilities,
it's a huge range, right?
People on the autism spectrum,
blind people, deaf people,
you name it, right?
And as it happens,
some of these technologies have
real problems because
of dispersion.
And they're well known in
the accessibility community, so
a good example is blind
accessible technologies.
If you want to make your
technology blind accessible,
and you're using specifically
Microsoft products,
you're in good shape.
Because you guys actually did
a great job, and that is,
you made [INAUDIBLE]
accessible two.
Which ended up being
a standard in certain ways,
in other platforms, has all
sorts of good properties, etc.
However, if you want your
application to work on phones
and Mac, and all sorts of stuff,
there are different technologies
you have to code for.
They work differently,
and sometimes they
don't work at all.
So for example, if you have
Oracle's accessibility
technology behind the scenes,
it is mostly incompatible for
screen reading technologies.
It's okay,
it works sometimes, but
not very well, so it's tricky.
The point is that this
version isn't just,
my plus operator is different.
It's that since there's both
a dispersion of the technologies
and a dispersion of
the implementations.
What you end up with
is inconsistency for
different kinds of people
like the blind, right?
That's the idea, but the problem
is, this is one of those nasty
problems that we've
talked about for
a long time in computer science.
I'm not really telling you
something you don't know,
necessarily.
We all know we have different
programming languages that we
have to pay developers money,
that's clear.
And this is also one of those
problems where one individual
scholar or industry
professional or even CEO
probably can't fix it on their
own, it's probably not possible.
So the question is, where there
other fields in science that had
big problems, and
what do they do?
To try to actually make
progress on problems that were
bigger than themselves,
all right, how did we do that?
And it turns out one of the most
common ways was, number one,
getting more evidence and
trying to hammer it down
very quantitatively.
In addition, in some fields but
not others, there
were also political movements,
so we'll talk about that a bit.
So one interesting thing
written by a paper by you two,
actually, you wrote this too?
You're Devanbu, great,
I love this paper, so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, it's true,
I do really like this paper.
So these three guys right
here happened to write this
really fantastic paper out of,
I think it was right, but, yes.
And they found something I
found really compelling,
I had no idea you guys would be
here, I didn't like plant this,
I promise, but-
>> It's okay if you did.
>> [LAUGH] It's okay if I did,
okay, great.
Well, the point is, what they
did is, they basically tried to
figure what caused developers
to believe things, right?
What did they believe,
and they categorized it in
a whole bunch of different ways.
And they found, and
this relates to previous
social science research,
also something I really
appreciate about the paper.
That things like personal
experience tend to be a little
bit more convincing to people
than research papers, right?
And so things like what I hear
from my colleagues or peers or
managers were little bit
ahead of research papers.
And there's a couple ways
you can interpret this.
And you guys were really
cautious in your paper, and
I will be a little
bit less cautious.
One way that you can interpret
this is that social theories
seems to indicate,
as far as I can tell,
that personal relationships
matter and that's probably true,
don't really have any
objections to that.
However, we might want to ask,
what is in these research papers
and what is the evidence
data for these things?
It's at least
a question we can ask.
And we might ask this because
when we look at people like
language designers, they make
a ton of testable claims.
So for example,
it's a little hard to see, but
you might believe that Ruby is a
dynamic, open source programming
language that focuses on
simplicity and productivity.
That's what they say.
We're not saying it's true or
false, is a library,
not a language.
But you can build powerful,
concurrent distributed
applications more easily.
More easily is a testable plan,
and you have to define it,
but it is something that could
be false and it could be true.
Perl is flexible and
powerful, cue for laughter.
And the point is, not so
much the language designers
are right or wrong, it's that,
people clearly have beliefs and
there's also marketing claims.
So it's a complicated situation,
of course you have to note,
there's no problem with saying,
I wanna get my tools out
there and get them used.
That's totally normal,
that's not a big deal.
But on the other hand,
that's the job of
the business community.
The job of the scholarly
community is to figure out
what's true, to figure out
something is true or false.
My job, I don't care about
marketing, I'm an academic, so
my job's a little different.
And as it turns out, in addition
to the research papers,
developers are somewhat
skeptical of research papers or
at least it appears so.
It's my impression
from the data and
you can disagree if I
got that wrong, but
I don't think you'd, yeah, see?
Okay, there we go.
So educators, as well,
people with direct expertise
in computer science education
actually don't understand the
problems their students have.
Wonderful, wonderful paper that
was just published by Brown and
Altadmri.
He collected 100 million
compiler errors.
So I'm gonna go
out on a limb and
say that's a sufficient
sample size.
And if you don't know any of
Neil Brown's work, it's amazing.
It's just absolutely fantastic,
scholarly, tour de
force type stuff.
And one of the things he
did in his recent paper was
[LAUGH] really made me laugh.
He basically asked top
conferences in computer science
and education like Acer but
also sort of local UK teachers,
and sort of like
a group of educators,
but not necessarily experts.
They might teach computer
science or do other things, but
in theory, they at least have
some connection to students.
But what he found was that
you can look at the data and
there are weak correlations,
but they're very weak.
Basically, if you actually track
data and then you go ask experts
what they think the answer is,
they really have no idea.
Or at least, a very weak
association with the truth.
And this turns out there's
at least some evidence.
I think that this paper is far
less compelling in terms of its
size of its data,
but nonetheless,
it's an interesting paper and
I wanna mention it.
There's a lot of work that's
gone on over the years on
Unified Modeling Language,
or UML.
Just show of hands,
how many people use
UML in here every day?
Yeah, this data, that's zero,
just for all those watching on
the old Internet, the data from
Marian Petry also shows this.
It basically says, we spend a
lot of time in academia talking
about the details of these
models and looking at them and
thinking about them and making
little theories about them and
stuff like that, and
nobody uses them.
There are a handful of
developers in her sample that
did it a little.
But generally speaking,
developers don't
use it that much.
>> I think there's a certain
[INAUDIBLE] with groups,
I mean so IBM's Rational has
a lot of customers and they're
printing courses for [INAUDIBLE]
people are quite happy with it.
>> Yeah, you and
I are in total agreement.
I mean, that's why I said, this
is a sample size of 50 people
that Marian Petry went and
asked.
Are those the right 50 people?
I have no idea.
But nonetheless, I think it's at
least a data point to consider,
even if I don't have
a better sample.
But yeah, you're completely
right, that's totally true.
Probably depends on
context in organization
and stuff like that.
Then we can ask the question,
what is actually in
the research papers?
Is there data in them, right?
That's a simple and
reasonable question.
Did scholars,
people paid to find the truth,
use the scientific method and
evidence?
And it turns out for programming
language data, a few years ago,
we ran a paper and
we looked at workshops.
So these are venues that
are not considered prestigious.
They're not the top venues.
They're just some places that
claim that they've gathered data
on these issues.
There's three of them.
One was called Empirical Studies
of Programmers.
That no longer exists.
There's another one called PPIG.
It's out of the UK.
A lot of Cambridge people were
doing it for a long time.
And there's another one called
which I actually participate in
and I like.
But nonetheless, it's reasonable
to ask what the evidence
standard is at such a venue.
And it turns out if you track
the data very carefully,
generally speaking, there
wasn't really much evidence.
And when I say very much,
if you read the details of this,
you find that it's
astonishingly low.
Even simple things like,
did they try to detect fraud,
would not be included
in studies on that.
Now I thought I was crazy
when we found this,
cuz we ended up tracking a lot
more papers than was in this.
We ended up with about a data
set of about 2,200 papers.
And we thought that
we were crazy,
because a lot of the papers that
were published at major venues,
small venues, that is,
dedicated to certain tasks
weren't really using evidence.
And so I thought that was insane
until this dissertation came out
by a guy name
Antti Juhani Kaijanaho.
Now, let me set the stage for
a second.
In the medical sciences,
which is very different
than computer science.
Between 1960 and 2000, the use
of these sorta fraud prevention
procedures, which were
developed for good reason,
increased past 1960 by 11.2%
a year after this guy named
Austin Bradford Hill
came into play.
We won't go into the details,
although they
are insanely fascinating.
He's the guy that figured out
that smoking causes lung cancer,
if you don't know,
Bradford Hill.
Increases it by 2,500% if
you smoke a couple packs,
I mean a couple a day.
Anyway, the point is,
compared to those procedures,
they ended up with something
like 110,000 studies or
somewhere in that ballpark.
By the end of 2012, we had 22.
So this includes top venues,
OOPSLA,
major academic venues that
are dedicated to program and
languages, software engineering,
any topic that you would think
might be relevant when we're
talking about wages in the size
of $330 billion in
the United States.
22 experiments, and
when I say 22 experiments,
I mean something specific.
This is what Kaijanaho
considered to be randomized
controlled trials.
And that matters because these
are fraud prevention procedures.
These are like,
you didn't try to cheat,
you had a control group.
If you said Ruby was good,
you compared it to something and
you didn't test yourself.
Just really, really basic stuff.
Now you might think this doesn't
matter until you start looking
at some other data from Andy Ko,
who's
at the University of Washington,
if you don't know him.
They analyzed four major
top conferences or
journals in software
engineering,
and they found something
also sort of odd.
On the one hand,
they did find that 77% of
papers do include some
kinda empirical evaluation.
So people are using some
kind of data of some kind.
However, even though software
engineering and in theory,
that's connected to something
related to people building
a software, only 27% evaluated
human use of the tool.
And of those,
62% of them tested themselves.
Right?
They said I have this great
tool, I tested it on me,
and it was kick ass.
That sought of idea.
Now this isn't my data.
This is something I've
confirmed [LAUGH] with Andy,
because I didn't believe it.
That's insane, that's, there's
no way that should be true.
There's no way that should
make a pass pure review, but
62% of the time
that's what happens.
Yeah?
>> What do these
numbers look like in?
>> I have no idea,
it's never been tested, but
I bet it'd be better,
but I don't know.
>> The culture is to use
a team of studies, and
more, I guess methodology
comes from psychology,
than we do in
software engineering.
>> Yeah, I would bet that
that'd be true as well, but
I've never seen a meta
analysis on it.
>> Are you gonna take a position
on natural experiments?
Do you have a feeling of what
natural experiments are at, and
basically what people would
get out of this for example?
>> Yeah, I'm happy to
talk about that, and
I know you're an MSR guy type,
that kind of stuff too.
I love them.
I think they're great.
I actually use your research in
my lab for generics because-
>> I hope.
>> It does,
actually it turns out, okay, so
let me explain this in
the context of medical history.
So in the 1940s,
this isn't on the slides, but
I know this off the top of my
head, cuz this is what I like,
this is what I love.
In the 1940s, when people were
coming back from World War II,
there was this huge opportunity
in the medical community,
because soldiers were
coming back, and
they had very serious problems.
These problems were really
serious to the point
where the nation go together and
said, we have to make sure we're
doing the best we can for
the soldiers as possible.
The only way they could get the
kind of sample sizes that people
believed was through the VA.
But there was [LAUGH] a problem.
It turns out the actual modern
way of conducting control
is only conduct finished in 1935
with Ronald Fisher's famous book
on experimental design, which
discussed like p-values, and
all that kind of stuff, and we
all know that there's problems
here and
there with that kind of stuff.
But nonetheless, in the 40s what
was happening is the VA started
doing sort of experiments, and
they couldn't really
do it at scale.
They'd go to this one hospital
and the doctor would be like,
I don't believe in
control groups, sorry,
and then you'd go to this other
hospital, and they'd be like,
yeah I'm not gonna use that
methodology sorry, and
there was other
people by about 10 or
15 years later that started
doing, very similar to
the natural terms you're talking
about like on GitHub, and stuff.
The evidence there is much
worse because they can't pull
down a repo from GiD,
that's a lot easier.
But they were doing
natural experiments, and
at the time these people hated
each other, they were fighting,
and they were fighting
because the one group,
the natural group was
like the epidemiologists.
Well that is what they called
themselves to my knowledge, and
then there was the other group,
which was the we need
to prevent fraud group,
both had totally legitimate
concerns, and so
what ended up happening is this
guy Austin Bradford Hill said,
why don't we just do both and
see if they match?
And so what happened was they
come up with this concept called
coherence, this is
Bradford Hill's big,
big idea, like fundamentally
change the world.
I don't mean that like in
a little way, it really did, and
it led to what is now known as
the phase randomized control
trial medicine, And eventually
something called Consort,
which is an evidence standard to
show replication of studies and
to diminish corporate fraud.
So the idea was really simple,
it's like if there's people
gathering natural data,
why would we possibly not
wanna take that into account?
On the other hand, since we know
that we can't control natural
data, we should experimentation
at various scales, and
the phased randomized control
trial allows for small and
big ones, to root out who
the liars are, right?
So it's a little bit of both,
you use a combination of
metrics and you check
whether they agree or not.
It turns out,
Christian's data on generics
matches what other scholars
do in experimentation.
You may not have known that,
but it's true.
It's true, so good job.
>> Can you send us those papers?
>> Yeah, sure no problem,
no problem.
>> Awesome, thanks.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm having trouble being
a developer [INAUDIBLE] but-
>> No, go ahead, please.
>> The comparison you're
making to medical studies, and
what's going on in computer
science it seems that there's
two things that are really,
very different.
One is the cost of doing
medical stuff versus doing,
it's not like you go find people
who actually are effectively
doing something, and totally
change our lives in medicine.
Hopefully not, right?
Cuz they now have to
take a different pill,
a different treatment,
instead of the other ones.
So the actual interim cost to
them is actually very low,
whereas with programming
you can't learn, I believe,
being skeptical and stuff,
you can't learn something
by some small experiment.
I actually have to get over
the whole hump of learning
everything, becoming proficient,
and knowing how to do things,
and spend weeks, months,
or even longer, perhaps,
getting proficient before I can
actually understand whether I
was really better off, so there
are a lot of to doing it, and
then, the other one is fraud.
The nature of fraud seems
to be really different.
Marketing guys
are all [INAUDIBLE],
but there's a lot less,
fraud happens differently,
I think, in the sense that I
actually can evaluate whether or
not I feel better off
using something or
believing something somebody
told me and applying it.
That's a real democratic
thing that takes place,
whereas with medicine,
it's like I have no idea.
Maybe he'll need me,
but if he doesn't, but,
the doctor says it's statistics
that's all beyond me, whereas
programming, each of us who
actually tries to go some path
can actually understand whether
we think it works or not.
So the ability to actually
commit fraud against me is a lot
harder because I figure
out it's a fraud myself.
>> Okay, I actually really
appreciate that question.
I really mean that, because I
think that this is something
that's really hard
to understand, and
that is that when you're talking
about people committing fraud
against you, you're definitely,
I assume, and correct me if I'm
wrong, you're talking about
like technical things.
If I tell you go use this
algorithm until it works,
you can try it, and if it's
not true, you can test that.
That's really easy, right?
>> Everything will go better.
For five years.
So for example.-
>> I believe you.
>> I'm not surprised
by that one bit, but
when I'm talking about
is slightly different.
We're talking about things that
are kind of harder to determine
for an individual, like I would
never tell you go use UML,
right, that would never
be in my lexicon.
But I I do think that there are
questions where you can look at
this coherence aspect, where
I like, what do we see from
natural experiments, and what
do we see from experiments that
are done at smaller scale, or at
different levels of scale, and
then we can ask, do they agree?
That was the key with
Bradford Hill, it wasn't saying,
we have to operationalized this
and now this drug is approved or
not, that's like
a government thing.
It was saying If we collect
any data that we can find,
from anyone, under any possible
set of conditions that we can,
does it agree or not?
That's the difference.
So it's more like a questioning
type of approach as opposed to
like you should go use UML,
which I don't really
believe in either so.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, I think so.
You're saying, there's
a lot of data out there and
how do we actually think and
understand.
>> Or even when they go get new
stuff, does it agree or not?
If Christian's data disagreed
with these other experiments, it
doesn't mean that one of them is
necessarily right, it could be
that they both screwed up their
methodology in different ways.
>> [INAUDIBLE] you were
saying that the kinds of
devices that online bring,
in all honesty,
to a natural experiment data
analysis, is complimentary dealt
with by devices that
in my opinion control
the experiment design so-
>> I think that was
Bradford Hill's view, yeah.
>> Okay, interesting, okay.
>> Okay so, but
I wanna end this talk by talking
about specifically experiments.
I think there's wonderful,
wonderful stuff out there that
is on the natural side,
I just don't know it as well.
I know some of it, but I know
the experiment side better,
and I wanna give you
a sense of what it shows,
and again, I'm not telling
you to go do this or that.
I'm just telling you what does
the data show and on whom.
So number one, if we talk about
students, now when I say this I
always like to talk about
students and professionals.
There's a really good reason for
this, and that is because People
program at different
periods of their life.
There are students in K through
12 that are learning programing
in kindergarten.
So it's completely reasonable
to ask how hard is it for
a kindergartener.
On the other hand, and
this is something Andy said in
one of his papers once actually,
Andy said but
people in industry actually
invent the technologies.
That's obviously true, right?
It seems like Microsoft builds
tools that get used by people.
And if we don't take
them into account either,
that seems spurious, right?
Why wouldn't we just
take both into account?
And then look at what
the data says as a whole.
Again, it's coherence,
right, this idea.
And so one of the things that
we like do when we do student
studies, is we like to sorta
tease out what things might be
impacting them, positive or
negative, either on average or
for groups.
And you'll see that grouping
matters in this context.
So one of the studies we did
a few years ago was on language
notation or syntax, right?
Now when I say syntax,
I use that term loosely because
computer scientists often think
about it like this is a parser,
right?
This is not what I mean.
What I mean is that different
programming languages have used
different notations to
mean different semantics.
And those can be done
in multiple ways.
Does that matter?
And it turns out,
one way that we did that is,
at least at the time, I grabbed
one particular language
that we made with rolling dice,
which we came up with.
Because of looking at Benjamin
Franklin's experiments from
the late 1700s on mesmerism,
which was just another
fraud technique.
And so what we did is I had my
graduate students sit around and
use a random number
generator and
generate a programming
language totally randomly.
The symbols were slash for
this and plus for
that and it's just random
symbols from the ASCII table.
And you have to try
to interpret that.
And we did that because we were
thinking that might give us
a baseline for languages.
It can't possibly be the case,
that languages aren't at
least as easy to understand
as one where we used
a random number generator.
So we called it a placebo
language, right.
Now, is placebo the right word?
You can debate it.
In the literature
in the late 1700s,
they called them
sham treatments.
And so whether you call it
placebo or a sham is relevant.
But that's the idea.
It's something we
shouldn't see work, right?
Or that you will expect
people to do poorly.
And that's surprisingly people
do very poorly when they're just
starting out with the language
that is designed randomly.
That's not as surprising.
What was more surprising
was that Perl and
Java didn't do any better,
and we know why.
The reason why is because the
specific word choices that we're
able to pull out using
a statistical procedure called
token accuracy mapping.
And it's really simple,
it works like this.
You basically take the examples
that people gave you and
they have to be small and
there's some rules about it.
And you have to use these
particular techniques to
evaluate it.
And you have to check
reliability between independent
observers of these techniques
and stuff like that.
And that stuff has to
be hammered out and
correct to do it right.
But if you do that,
you can actually see the areas
of a programming language
that novices did or
did not do correctly.
And it turns out,
a lot of the things we take for
granted like for in a loop
mean nothing to novices.
So for example, if you use
the word repeat over for,
it triples their accuracy
on that token, triple.
If you use equals instead
of double equals, and
you'll overload it for
both the assignment and
equality, which you think might
be bad, I thought was bad.
It turns out, it has no impact
on assignment and it gives you
an increase on the equality some
of them eight fold in accuracy.
And when you think about it,
that kinda makes sense.
It's misleading, right,
to a novice that hasn't
already been trained, right?
Now you might also think,
this is a small study.
This study was replicated,
I don't know, a bunch of times,
and then we ended up publishing
two of those replications.
One of them was small
scale with 18 people,
the other had 60 something,
right?
Same answer for both, right?
Different samples
all that stuff.
But you might think,
if we did a natural experiment
like we look at Neil Brown's
data, maybe we don't get
the same answer, but we do.
In fact, it turns out that the
regions token accuracy mapping
predicts would be hard for
novices are exactly the same
things we find in these
massive natural datasets.
They get the same answer.
But, and this is an important
but, this is novices, right?
This doesn't mean this will help
you, right, not necessarily.
So what we need to do is we
need to also ask questions that
look at different
kinds of people.
So one of the ones that we've
kind of had fun getting hate
mail about is the static versus
dynamic typing debate, right?
How many people have heard
of this debate, right?
You don't have take a stand.
I'll give you three
possible positions.
Position one is I
believe static,
position two is I
believe dynamic, and
position is either I don't know
or maybe somewhere in-between.
So, anyone for static?
Anyone for dynamic?
And anyone that wants
to be on the fence?
Okay, good.
So as it turns out,
this is two particular papers.
I'm gonna show you
a synopsis of a bunch more.
One is from.
If you look on this particular
graph, it's kind of hard to see.
These are box box,I don't really
wanna explain all the details.
But at the end of the day,
static typing allow these
individuals to write correct
programs defined operationally
by the paper more quickly,
right?
And we know why.
And the reason why is because
developers have dynamic typing.
What they do when they want to
use a function is to go look for
what they pass to the function.
And if you videotape them and
you take out that time,
it matches.
In other words,
if you have dynamic typing and
you wanna use a function,
you have to know what
the passed to it.
And we thought, maybe we could
throw that effect away if we
just put in the documentation
what you passed to it.
Turns out that doesn't work. Why?
I don't know but
that's the answer.
And then when you look at these
things, one thing that people
often concern about with
experiments is replication, and
for good reason.
Because replication is hard.
And unfortunately as well,
other disciplines have things
called evidence standards.
And this is a technical term,
this is not something
I'm making up.
Evidence standard is a formal
document adopted by a community
that says, you must follow
these particular standards.
A good example would be
if you have statistics,
you must report the p-value and
the effect size would be
a common example, right?
And they just says,
you don't get published
unless you have that, right?
Or another one might be, you
must have a control word, right?
It's something very simple.
You can decide as a community
for this particular venue or
this journal.
If you don't at least have this
fraud prevention procedure in
place, you won't get published.
The most common one in
medicine is called CONSORT.
And this one was designed in
part because of all sorts of
problems in the 60s.
But also because of some
famous court cases in the 2000
where corporations were
committing fraud that was
murdering people, right?
Which is not pleasant to say but
it's true.
So they have this things called
Register Randomize Control
Trials, it's a fraud prevention
technique, etc, etc.
So, we try, even though I
work in a discipline that
has no evidence standards for
these things,
I have evidence standards.
And so one thing that we do is
we replicate our experiments in
all sorts of different ways.
So for example, are statically
typed APIs faster to use?
This is two studies, I mentioned
at the top, the answer was yes.
They had the same effect size,
effectively, the same answer,
different people.
Sometimes different countries,
right?
Is the previous finding
only a matter of syntax?
Turns out if you twiddle with
the type declarations to make
them wrong, then yes,
it's misleading, and
that's what happens, right.
Can documentation compensate for
the positive effect
of certain types?
Turns out the answer is no,
it has a small impact but
the effect size is only 0.14, so
it's not that big
of a difference.
Do generics help
with static typing?
Turns out, yes, but
only in certain regions
of the code, right?
So it turns out if you have
generics on method declarations,
that tends to help.
But if you have to use and
write your own generics classes,
that gets nasty, right?
What about IDEs?
So some of the previous studies
were done in text editors only.
It could be that just doing it
in a text editor is the problem,
and that if you just had really
good IDE support that that
would help.
Turns out, it doesn't,
same effect size regardless of
having a really up-to-date IDE.
What about a benefit for dynamic
type systems if you just to go
totally nuts and
you try to design static typing?
Well it's insane, you just come
up with the craziest examples
where you have to have triply
nested generics with question
mark extends or
some other nasty stuff.
It turns out if you do that,
there is a way to see a small
benefit from dynamic typing.
But it's so esoteric that it's
hard to see most developers
actually doing that in practice,
although you could verify that
with a natural experiment,
all right?
In fact, you did, which is why
we did it that way, right?
And then finally this one
isn't published yet, but
some people argue if only
we had type inference,
a lot of work has
gone at Poppel and
places like that to do type
inferred type systems.
It could be that that
inference is what helps, but
remember the theory here.
The theory is that if you
don't know what to pass,
that's the cause at the time.
So we would expect to see
no effect and we don't,
same answer, right?
So we're talking maybe
10 to 15 replications,
I forget how many off
the top of my head now.
And that data seems to match
with people doing natural
experiments, right?
So it's not perfect,
but that's where it is.
So two other examples,
just to give you a taste, right?
One is, how many people have
heard of aspect-oriented
programming, right?
How many believe it's helpful?
How many believe it's not?
And how many believe that
it's either unclear or
you're not sure?
Okay, so there isn't a lot of
data, there's only a handful of
experiments, but they seem
to show it has no impact.
The types of things the guy
that made it, well,
there's a few people and
they argue about it.
But one of the people that did
it was Gregor Kiczales back in
the day.
And they made arguments saying
basically that it would help for
certain kinds of code, like
logging and stuff like that.
And you can find
some effects for
logging that are kind of small,
but almost nothing else, right?
So it could be that it's
great for logging, but
that's just really isn't useful. Otherwise-
>> That seems to be the only
argument I've ever heard for
aspect-oriented is logging
>> And in fact, the data
shows it's the only one they've
been able to document as true,
and the effect size is small for
that effect as well.
I forget which task it was in
here, but it's one of these,
there's a teeny,
teeny tiny effect, and
then the rest is just in a wash.
So your hunch is what's
supported by the data as well.
So in any case, not much in
the way of replications for
that experiment but you can
try to invalidate them through
natural or experimentation
through coherence.
And the final one is one
that one of my students did,
I just think it was fun.
We have heard for years that
lambdas were like the best
thing in the world
from many people.
And so we were curious, right?
So we decided to
test just one thing,
cuz you can only test
one thing at a time.
There's no replications on this,
to my knowledge, and
I don't know of any
natural experiments.
Maybe they're there or
maybe there are some pieces in a
couple of papers here and there,
but like I said, it's not as
much my area of expertise.
And so what we did
was we thought, okay,
maybe this is different
across experience levels.
Maybe you have to be really,
really experienced with
lambdas to use them correctly.
Or maybe it's the case
that it'll be the same,
you get this big effect across
the board, we weren't sure.
So we tested freshmen in
college, sophomores in college,
juniors in college, and
seniors in college.
They learned lambda somewhere
around their junior year or so.
So they would have known
something about them.
And for the professionals that
we used, we got people that were
serious devs that knew something
about functional programming.
They were self-proclaimed
experts in functional program.
They know what lambdas are,
there's no debate, right?
But when you break down the
data, there was no impact for
the professionals.
They could solve the tasks about
the same amount of speed as
using iterator in C++,
all right?
This is just, again, one
language, I'm not saying C++ has
the best lambdas, I think
they're kind of atrocious but
that's not the point.
Well no, that's not fair,
they're not atrocious, they have
particular syntactic properties
that I think could be improved.
There, how's that?
Well it's true, I mean,
language design is hard and
sometimes when you're
trying to be general,
sometimes it's easy to get too
general or not general enough.
And that's a difficult problem.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Conclusions
about lambdas and
what you did versus
lambdas in C++.
>> Okay,
that's a great question.
And the answer's you can't,
right?
So this particular test only
compared two things, and
that's C++ lambdas and
C++ iterators.
So we can't necessarily say that
this would be true in Java,
other languages.
And some languages
have very different ways
of handling lambdas.
And in fact, they use them in
different contexts, right?
So for example, the one area
that, if I was to guess where
lambdas could be really helpful,
there's some really neat stuff
they do with lambdas in
the JDK for a concurrency.
I have no idea if this would
be validate in an experiment
or not.
But it wouldn't surprise me
if there is a benefit there
that could be
documented possibly.
But I could be wrong, I don't
really know cuz we haven't
tested that particular thing.
But in comparing C++ to lambdas
versus iterators, we found
a very, very, strong negative
impact for people with less
experience compared to doing
a similar thing with iterators.
And for professionals, we found
no positive impact, right?
Again, it doesn't mean you
should or shouldn't use lambdas.
It has nothing to do with that.
What it means is that there was
a technical team of people
that spent years and
years developing a spec and
nobody did a test, right?
Maybe it's syntax problem and
they should have checked that.
Or maybe lambdas really don't
have a benefit, that could be
the case, right, at least
in one particular language.
But these were added all
over Java, C++, whatever.
>> [INAUDIBLE] People
think that better, okay,
and before they can
really know what it does
cuz novices just don't count for
that much.
In the scheme of things, they
won't cost you $300 billion.
>> Right.
>> You have to actually
do it for a language,
develop a whole of professionals
who are expert at using it.
And then actually measure it,
and by that point everybody's
pretty much moved on, except for
the guys who are kinda stuck
in a belief system that's
part of their world.
So I don't know what you would
be advocating practically for
applying what you're saying.
>> Sure, I'm happy to
answer that, actually.
So what I'm advocating for
specifically, I don't
have like a plan for
action in the slides cuz I'm
not trying to necessarily
convince you to go do something.
But what I would say is that
other scientific disciplines
break down big problems into
manageable chunks, right?
So for example, medicine,
we have early experiments which
are either phase one or
before that.
Where they're really, really
tightly controlled and they try
to come up with the theory
why something could be true.
But we all know that just
because you kill a bacteria in a
lab doesn't mean that you're not
gonna kill the person using it.
We all know that, right?
You would agree, right?
And with computer science,
it needs I think that one path
forward would be to
do something similar.
So for example,
if you wanna change C++ for
the whole world, that could
impact a lot of developers,
then there's a process.
You have to have some low level
experiments that at least shows
it's plausible.
And then if those worked out, we
need some natural experiments,
and we need some
experiments over here.
And then if you go through
this chain, then we say okay,
the evidence is sufficient,
put it in C++.
But it seems right now that
the process is just kind of like
people decide and
they might not do a good job.
>> Yeah, I don't disagree with,
my question what you said
other than [INAUDIBLE].
One thing that does seem like
there might be some hope here is
if you ignore programming
languages and stuff like that
will be far less impactful
than features in programs.
And when people develop
programs, they put features
in them like my favorite feature
in life is the ribbon in Office.
And I wonder did that really
improve productivity of people
who were using Office or
not, all their arguments and
[INAUDIBLE]?
And so it makes me wonder if you
could actually practically apply
this in teaching a software
engineering course.
That basically said here's a
methodology you can use when you
put features into a program
you're developing for
users that would actually
let you know whether or
not Those features were
a benefit to them now.
Could you do
something like that?
>> Yeah, in terms of features,
I don't think we have any
disagreement there as well.
And I actually do teach stuff
like this in my classes as well
for reasons like that.
For example,
in software engineering,
I'm not talking about
programming languages.
But I do want them to at least
understand evidence, for or
against procedures, yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah.
>> A world where people
developed applications people
use, and actually understand
these kinds of things, and
actually develop things that
actually will be valuable.
>> Yeah,
there's some speculation,
and I don't know if it's true,
but it would not surprise me.
Oftentimes in university
education for
computer science, I hypothesize,
but do not claim to be correct,
that one of the reasons why
we've done such a poor job.
And we have really done
a terrible job on using data and
evidence for many things is
because we don't really require
any education on it, right?
Like if you work in some
scientific disciplines you have
lab hours, right?
And you have to run
experiments on stuff.
And we do that with programming.
We're pretty good I
think as a community of
trying to make something work.
Hacking it together and
testing it,
run on the debugger whatever
your methodology is.
But when it comes to knowing
these sort of bigger problems
that actually do impact a lot
of our productivity, that impact
the tools we use, not just the
languages but the tools in our
processes and all these things,
less so, right?
In any case, language wars
is obviously complicated.
Like I said, this problem is
much bigger than me, it's much
bigger than all of us, it's
much bigger than one company,
it's a hard problem, right?
There's a reason it's
persisted for a long time, but
it also hasn't been
studied very carefully.
There's not much data,
as I think is clear
from the evidence.
There are some papers here and
there that are making some
progress or trying to, and we're
trying to start a community of
people that are doing this.
So for example we have
Schloss Dagstuhl next year,
which I'm sure a name
I'm butchering,
which is basically a group of
academics coming together to try
to say we need to
make some progress.
And it needs to actually
use the scientific method.
So in any case,
thanks for listening and
I very much appreciate
all of your questions.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> More questions?
>> So one comment.
So I think the issue here
I think is a cultural one.
Programming languages
people view programming as
a mathematical task,
like proving.
If I'm trying proving something,
what really matters is the
notation on your definitions and
your rules of inference,
things like that.
And whether or not these
notations are accessible to
hundreds of people, or
thousands of people who find it
appealing is irrelevant, right?
And those of us doing
empirical work,
I think, on the software
engineering side we're sort of
viewing programming as a human
behavior to be studied as
a human behavior using
experimental methods.
So I think these two
disciplines have very different
perspectives.
Programming designers don't,
I mean,
I'm generalizing a bit here so
people who design language
like Python have a very
different perspective.
But redefining a language design
like Pascal or TypeScript and so
on, you're coming from a very
different perspective.
Which is,
what is the right notation,
does it have
the right semantics?
Can I prove the right
properties?
>> Yeah, yeah, that's true.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
if no human ever used
programming languages,
I think that that perspective
would be valid, right?
But you are right, that's
absolutely what's going on,
is that these communities,
they've existed for a long time,
and they kinda have their thing.
They do type
soundness proofs and
they twiddle with some
semantics and stuff and
there's nothing wrong with that.
That's totally okay.
>> [INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
we have a diverse group,
let's just say that [LAUGH].
>> Do you have there, too?
>> Do we have?
>> Do you have?
>> Yeah, [LAUGH] for sure.
Well, we're trying to get a lot
of people outside of computer
science as well,
people that understand evidence
standards and stuff like that.
Well, I've tried to get one,
I don't know if he'll go, but
in any case.
At least some people that do,
there's other evidence,
I'll get to you in
just a second, sorry.
There's people,
there's other evidence
standards besides the ones
used in medicine.
Medicine uses consort, which
is by far the most rigorous of
anything out there that I
know of for empiricism.
Cuz if you don't do it right,
you die, right?
That's kind of a big deal.
But other communities have
been either adopting consort
wholesale or they develop
their own because of the law.
So for example,
in education they use
the What Works Clearinghouse.
It's not as rigorous, but it has
fraud prevention standards and
stuff like that.
I think he was first and then.
>> So I just really appreciate
that point because something
that's always been a mystery
to me is having grown up in
universities where you have
lots of language designers and
working with language
designers and safety debates.
And programming,
that's why I came to this,
sort of lived through
a lot of programming wars.
How come all the languages
everybody actually uses
that are really successful in
terms of broad communities
are horrible?
>> [LAUGH]
>> So actually, the only paper I
know of that looked at the
adoption in a really rigorous
way that I would consider as
scientific as we have right now,
is this wonderful, wonderful
paper by Leo Meyerovich.
It's this guy that graduated
from Berkeley a bunch of,
you know this paper, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Graduated from Berkeley
a bunch of years ago and
I forget the name of it, but
it's empirical studies
on language adoptions.
So I'm happy to send it to you.
>> Socio-PLT, is that-
>> No no, that's the early one.
The Socio-PLT paper
is fantastic, but
the one that had the biggest
dent, I think, was the empirical
studies on language adoption or
something like that.
Socio-PLT tried to come
up with a theory, and
the other one was what
actually occurs, right, yeah.
Both are good, though.
But like the Socio-PLT paper had
this fascinating observation
that religious communities
that are hard to get into,
people tend to stick with them.
This is what I was
about to get to.
It could be the case that's
part of it for languages.
Like if it's nasty or
like, I learned it,
I am not doing anything else.
But I don't think so, I think
that his paper leans more toward
that it's a social construct,
like if you work at a particular
company that uses x
you tend to use it.
If you use
a programming language,
you tend to use the ones
that you heard about before.
So for example, if I recall
correctly, and I'm not prepared
to talk about this paper, but
off the top of my head, I wanna
say that the strongest predictor
of what language you'll use next
is the one that you used
previously, stuff like that.
>> Yeah, those are great
theories, I guess,
from the scientific side.
But just observing this
over my career, okay.
COBOL became what it was
partly because was really,
really horrible.
Because businesses said
this is what you did.
You bought IBM, and you could
express big numbers in a world
without floating point, you
could represent accurately with.
Okay, so there's some things
that really compelled people for
business reasons to do that.
But okay, PASCAL came along and
that was really
successful because everybody
was forced to learn it.
It wasn't successful, but for
a while it looked like
it was successful.
Everybody was forced to learn
in computer science departments
which were all like
new in the 80s.
Visual Basic came along, I
remember making fun of a friend
of mine who was looking for
Visual Basic programmers cuz I
was a C, C++,
that kind of thing.
And he says, look.
My experience, and again,
his experience is that,
he was able to get cheaper and
more productive guys.
He ran a consulting business,
who could actually
produce code faster.
And so they have an argument
that people got into that, and
unless they're in it,
yes, they're used to it,
they know the language.
We tried to get them to go to
C#, no like, what're you doing,
we love Visual Basic.
And then the Web thing comes,
and they're all different
reasons, maybe, why people found
something that became a great
tool for what they had to do,
and then the thing becomes.
But I think the reasons
actually are kind of dirty,
like let's try and illustrate
here about why it happens.
So this thing you were saying
about understanding kind of
the human nature aspect of how
humans interact with programming
languages and environments is
probably far more relevant.
It sort of goes back in, saying,
all the analysis of types and
what languages should look like,
productivity, and
10% improvement here is a social
human factor, it seems to be.
>> Well, I don't think
necessarily that Meyerovich
would disagree with that.
These human constructs,
that's why I'm saying,
it's kind of a social problem.
Right, this is what I mean
by that, is we're saying
effectively the same thing
in very different ways, but-
>> Yeah, I mean,
it's [INAUDIBLE] you gave
about communities and
things like that.
I think for
someone which is, but
I think there are a whole
bunch of different reasons.
>> Yeah, I agree, and that's
actually what the [INAUDIBLE]
paper shows,
is that it's complicated, right?
Adoption's a complicated thing,
yeah.
>> So I wanted to ask kind of
two questions that are related
to each other, which is
about how do you evolve?
So the first question is about,
let's say a language came out.
There's like 15
studies that show that
the use of angle brackets for
generics turns out to be worse
than if you use something else.
How do you evolve that language,
given that it's already out
there, and there's code
written in that language?
And the second thing is,
we have a community of
researchers who apparently in
software engineering don't often
do randomized controlled trials.
How do you evolve them to start
doing that without saying,
tomorrow the standard
is changed, and
we're gonna reject all papers
that don't do these randomized
control trials perfectly.
Which is the kind of thing
that's actually happening with
user studies in some
of these fields.
Like in the ASC conference or
in FSC,
where it's not uncommon
to user studies.
Now all of a sudden people who
are good at evaluating user
studies are like, well,
that's not done properly, so
I'm gonna reject the paper.
So there's no way to teach
the community how to do
these things without
making them perfect.
How do you evolve both
the languages, the programs, and
the people over time to
get to better standards?
>> Boy, both of those questions
are super hard, [LAUGH] so
thanks.
No, let me do the second one
first, because I think that
it's not necessarily easier
from a social perspective.
But I think that you're
completely right.
The implication of
the question is that
this is not boolean, right?
Not only is it not the case
that all papers should be
randomized controlled trials,
that's weird.
That there needs to be
coherence, but in addition to
that, even people's
understanding isn't boolean.
We don't teach how to do
this stuff in school,
not really,
at least in computer science.
We don't really teach it at
conferences, and you can't fly
around to every conference and
do workshops and stuff.
I know there's been some, and
I've done some, but that's hard,
so the question is,
how do you do it?
And the answer is,
I don't know, exactly,
I think this is a problem
that's bigger than me, right?
But my suspicion is,
there's probably
an educational component,
we should try to get it in
schools more over time.
I think that we should try
to get it into conferences,
in terms of workshops
to help people.
I think that would be good.
I think that The National
Science Foundation giving money
to it, meaning they should
get communities together that
are both scientists and
practitioners.
We need people that are in the
trenches not only to study but
to give feedback.
But we also need people that
understand all the data and
stuff like that.
In medicine, they took
a totally different tact for
changing it, and that was
they changed the law, right?
And specifically,
what happened was, in the 40s,
doctors didn't wanna use
the scientific method, right?
Cuz they believed
they were right, and
they were trying to
help their patients, so
Congress changed the law.
And they started to say, this
happened really early, actually.
So in 1902, they changed the law
so that if you were to give
a drug, you had to say
what was in it, right?
And that sounds today totally
obvious, but you had to say what
was in it, but you didn't have
to say whether it works, right?
And then in 1927, they created
the FDA, and they said, okay,
well, we don't know what the
answer is or how to evaluate it.
But we do know that we should
check if it kills people, and
sometimes it was.
So the question is
then how do we proceed?
Do we get communities to
have minimal policing and
pop it up over time?
Do we do training,
do we do all of the above?
Since I'm kind of
a coherence guy,
I kind of take all of
the above approach.
But I really don't like
exactly what you just said,
which is just like this
is totally imperfect,
we need to reject
everything like that.
I think that's nuts,
I think this is learning, right,
researchers learn too, right?
Maybe you disagree,
but I doubt you do.
But yeah, okay, so
then there's the first question,
which is, what do we do
about evolving the language?
I think this is actually
really hard, so
I like to solve really easy
problems, right, or try to.
So there's been a number of
approaches I think we all know.
Some languages take
the approach of,
we're only going to
add the language, and
we never change anything
that came before it.
And then there's the opposite,
like the Python 3 to 2 debate,
how many people know that,
I don't.
So it's kinda like
they changed some stuff
that broke backward
compatibility.
And so I'll tell you two things
that we do in our lab, but
we have it easy
compared to all of you.
In my lab,
we developed a programming
language called Quorum.
It's only used by
about 2500 kids, but
that's still a lot of kids,
right, over the world.
And so we make a rule, we say,
we're gonna break backward
compatibility once a year.
And we can do that because it's
mostly teachers when you work in
education.
The next generation of kids that
comes around the next year does
not care at all, right,
because that's not the point.
But that's not fair,
that's not an easy thing.
If you're working in C++,
then you can't just say,
sorry, we don't have
pointers anymore cuz
you're gonna break
a little code, right?
I'm gonna go on a limb, right?
So the question is,
how do we do that?
I mean, I think, again, it's a
multi-pronged thing, on the one
hand, we have to get people to
understand even what evidence
is, so that they think that
maybe there's a need for that.
We need to train people
on what the impacts are,
and go for the biggest ones.
But we also have to do it
in such a way that we don't
break the things that'll cause
the most harm to the community,
like turning off pointers all of
a sudden, and stuff like that.
Well, that's just an example,
but you get the idea,
right, features that
are fundamentally game breaking.
On the other hand,
it could be that for
some of these languages, over a
20, 30, 50, or 100-year period,
that we can start to change
a few things here and
few things there on a schedule.
Where everybody knows it's
coming, everybody knows what
the plan is, and everybody
knows what the evidence is, and
can try to refute it.
Right, they can say, C++ on
this date is changing to this,
and all of the compilers
that people do.
And if you don't like that,
here's the study methodologies,
the data for them, and
if you don't like it,
you can try to refute it.
But this is Andy's pipe
dream world where that-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Really, did they try that?
>> I don't know about that,
but that's a great thing
because earlier you said Y2K
only comes around however often.
And you just came up with a way
of having it happen every few
years [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] Well, I said-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I don't know if that's quite
fair because Y2K was a problem
that was deeply rooted.
But like suppose we said,
it depends on the amount of
change that you're requesting,
all right?
>> [INAUDIBLE] old code perhaps-
>> Well, not any subtraction or
change, so an addition wouldn't-
>> Yeah, that's fair,
if you had some rules about
that, but that [INAUDIBLE].
>> So subtractions would need
more evidence than addition.
You'd have to be sensible,
right?
>> Does anyone know how many
version of C++ implementations
there are that do not
parse by every compiler?
>> Hundreds?
>> There are literally hundreds,
and that didn't involve that
many official versions of C++.
And yet there are still so many
that can't read certain, lots of
code by Microsoft can't be read
by non-Microsoft compilers.
>> Yes, that's true, but
I discovered an interest in
[INAUDIBLE] Visual Studio team
[INAUDIBLE].
And it was this that,
there was something about who's
checking into our tree and
doing some stuff and signing
bugs and people [INAUDIBLE].
I discovered that, [INAUDIBLE]
color changed everything.
That there's this one guy who's
checking in all of these changes
to virtually everything
throughout the entire tree.
It turned out to be the guy from
Visual Studio whose job it was
to make our code work with the
latest compilers [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH] Nice, yeah?
>> So it's very agreeable, and
kind of obvious the way you've
laid it out, that we should
have more control studies and
better examples for
these things.
But I wanted to ask,
the example in almost all of
your The running theme in all of
your examples is this
idea of productivity.
And I'm wondering if that's,
is that an innocent
choice of metric?
Why is that the thing that
we're looking to optimize for
our study?
>> No, that's a great question,
actually.
So it's not the only thing
that has been studied in
the literature, but it's one
that is often mentioned in terms
of time, because time costs.
That's usually why
people study it.
For example, if you know that
you're gonna reduce the time
to fix compiler error.
Here's an example.
There's a natural study,
not a controlled study, but
it's a really excellent
natural study by Brett Becker.
This guy in the UK that is kind
of a young dude that maybe isn't
that well known yet,
but should be,
because his work is fantastic.
And Brett did this study on
changing compiler errors to be
more friendly to people.
And he did just really obvious
things, like instead of saying,
eat my face, it would say, hey,
there's an error on line five.
It's a terrible example, I
don't know why I said that, but
just bear with it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The point is,
he would take messages that
were perhaps esoteric, and
he would do his best.
He didn't have a methodology for
knowing what to change in them,
but he wanted to try.
And he found some percentage
decrease in the amount of time
to remove errors.
Now in that case, it's time, so
you could call it productivity.
But he was thinking that
if that was a developer,
that would cost, right?
So that costs money.
But on the other hand,
that's obviously not the only
thing that you care about.
You could analyze
comprehension metrics,
you could analyze accuracy.
So sometimes we do accuracy
studies for syntax,
like how accurately can they put
in the syntax, stuff like that.
And I think all of those
things should be studied.
Again, it's coherence, right?
You want all of these studies to
know the totality of evidence.
But time is a common theme for
that reason, so yeah?
>> Well, there's a dominant
thing that's changing,
it is in software,
which is not the time you
spend developing the software.
It's always the maintenance and
things like that that seem to be
a bigger cost factor probably.
>> Right,
saw that notes of that.
>> But
now it's the vulnerabilities.
>> The what?
>> The vulnerabilities
in software.
By producing software with
vulnerabilities, every day you
read in the paper that the
tremendous cost to society and
companies and everything
else by the vulnerabilities.
>> Yeah, that's a great idea.
I've heard that before, right?
I gave a talk at CME once and
someone mentioned that.
And I think it's spot on,
right, why not?
Why not try to figure out can
we reduce that a little bit too?
That's great, yeah.
Now this is what I love about
this coherence idea is it
doesn't say, this person's
right, that person's wrong,
whatever.
It says, why don't we
just look at it all and
then try to reverse engineer it.
Natural studies are good,
controlled studies have
a different purpose and
they work at different scales
for a good reason, right?
They let you try crazy things,
right?
Anyway, other questions?
All right, well,
thank you very much for coming,
I appreciate it.
>> [APPLAUSE]